la crisis en guatemala se extiende las
imágenes de una parte del congreso en
llamas así lo revelan este sábado 21 de
noviembre cientos de ciudadanos se
lanzaron a las calles para manifestar en
contra del gobierno
su argumento rechazar el presupuesto
previsto para el año 2021 que algunos
sectores consideran elevado los altos
niveles de deuda y las dificultades que
afronta el país producto de la pandemia
generaron malestar en la población
[Risas]
la ira de los manifestantes provocó que
un grupo ingresará violentamente a la
sede del parlamento y quemarán varias
oficinas la situación generó choques
entre los ciudadanos y efectivos de las
fuerzas de seguridad
el presidente del país alejandro
giammatei rechazó los actos reiteró que
se tiene el derecho de manifestar
conforme la ley pero tampoco podemos
permitir que se banalice con la
propiedad pública o privada al que se le
compruebe su participación en estos
hechos delictivos le caerá todo el peso
de la ley el presupuesto para el año
2021 el mayor de la historia del país ha
traído problemas en el seno del poder
ejecutivo tal es la crisis que el
vicepresidente guillermo castillo le
pidió al presidente alejandro giammattei
que emitieran que presentemos ambos
nuestra renuncia al cargo el de
presidente y yo de vicepresidente de la
república pero que lo hagamos juntos
para descartar esas ideas deliciosas es
así
que se dice que se tienen o que se
piense que yo le quiero dar golpe
quedarme en su puesto el plan de gasto
de la nación aprobado por el congreso
ronda los 12 mil 900 millones de dólares
al menos 1300 millones de dólares por
encima del establecido para el ejercicio
fiscal del año 2020 previo a los
incidentes en el congreso el jefe de
estado había mostrado disposición de
analizar algunas modificaciones